[Music]
[Applause]
let's off-site track and y'all hear me
fine
all right good thank you for thumbs up
welcome to my top recreating retro
computer art with JavaScript my name is
Sherman
it's weird to word first name so it sure
and mins sure spaceman it's a little bit
of unusual name down sites of that is
that online forms really don't like it
when you have a name so all of you here
working on like you know client-side
validation keep that in mind on the
bright side though my SEO is really
great if you look up my name it's a
first touch result and I didn't have to
do anything so life is good I am from a
small country in Southeast Asia called
Malaysia and yeah we have actually
another Malaysian in the house here are
waging that was on the stage at CSS
comps so proud to represent my country
and I actually live in New York right
now where I initially moved to to attend
something called the recurse Center and
it's a woo RC in the house okay so for
those of you who may not know what the
rican Center is it is a programís
retreat that's based in New York City
it's free you can do one week six weeks
or twelve weeks and it's a really great
place to rediscover the joy in
programming so if you want to take some
time off to let you know really learn
something you need to learn this is a
great place to do it
and I always plug it because this is the
reason why I'm giving this talk here
today like everything they have provided
me have has enabled me to pursue
creative programming so creative
programming right I like programming and
I like art a lot I was I learned how to
draw before I learn how to code and here
are some of the pieces of work that I've
made in the past year and I really enjoy
using programming to create code and
most recently I've been really inspired
by retro computer art so what happened
was that I discovered this magazine from
1976 to 1978 and it was edited by a
computer artist Gracie Hart line based
in California in the United States
this was the first ever computer
magazine that was entirely dedicated to
computer graphics and art and as you can
see here the title you know inexpensive
graphics from the storage category
category really dates it and I got these
images from a website called the recode
project com
the site is no longer up but it was a
great resource to help you kind of just
look through what was cutting edge
graphics back then and as you can see
it's mostly black and white text-based
lines geometric shapes today we would
call it minimalist or lo-fi it's an
aesthetic and so it was really fun to
look at and also to think about because
most of the times the work published is
just the artwork itself there wasn't a
lot of algorithms most of the time to be
like some description of the technology
used and maybe like some of the
techniques but no actual algorithms so
the whole purpose of the website that
hosted this magazine the read the
archive for this magazine were like well
can we try and reverse engineer it can
we look at a piece and try to figure out
how it was me hmm and so that's exactly
what I saw fell into and so this entire
talk will be about the research that I
did and also some of the attempts at
recreating these works so let's first
talk about computer art what is computer
art a lot of us have our own ideas of
what computer art is and you know it's
probably right in my definition computer
art is any art that in which computers
play a role in the production or the
display of the artwork so today that can
include anything from that say you know
building a image using like Photoshop or
illustrator or 3d graphics they are we
are the latest you know hottest thing
which is like you know deep learning art
ai art but we're not gonna be talking
about any of that today we're gonna be
talking about the really really early
years of computer graphics this was why
computer graphics became accessible and
it'll be about how people took you know
all those technologies and use it to
make art so the decade I'm focusing on
is the 1950s to the 1970s
and this is really the crucial point
where computer art was just becoming a
thing so everything seems like an white
haha
so to talk about retro computer and
first need to talk about what computers
were like back then the reason being
that contacts really matters when you're
talking about history and if you
understand the tools and the techniques
that are available to people at a time
you can understand why certain pieces
had a certain aesthetic or you know why
was it done that way and so it helps you
appreciate a lot to work a little bit
better here's a computer that was
introduced in 1959 and this is the IBM
7090 data processing system it's not
just computer it's a data processing
system really fancy it would take up an
entire room you can see like men I think
tape readers to the back you know
consoles and punch cut readers and it
was introduced at a really cool price of
three million dollars back then if you
convert it to currency today Counting
for inflation it would be something like
19 million US dollars which is really
really expensive and so what this man
was that computers were really difficult
to come by the people who could afford
it were people in universities research
labs the military government agencies so
they were very scarce of a resource the
imagine just calling IBM up and be like
I would like to buy a computer when 19
you can tell this all right your check
you know and most of the time people
wouldn't even like interface with the
computer they would write programs for
it using a punch cut writer which is
like a typewriter and you punch your
code and it will punch you into a punch
card you would take that stack of punch
cuts hand it to a little man behind the
door and five minutes later you get your
results back and so if you ever get
impatient waiting for webpack to built
think about this so it's different
different time back then right like you
know Scott's pea sauce takes a lot of
time and so they were mainly use for
scientific and mathematical applications
like I said mostly by scientists
mathematicians in research labs or you
know
universities so I want to show you some
examples of companies that really
contribute it to the field of computer
graphics the first being Boeing and they
actually coined the term computer
graphics and they were one of the very
first few people to use computer
graphics in the design work so they were
use use this to design cockpits to
animate the different like reaches of
the limbs for a pilot and a cockpit they
use it for landing simulations here is a
first airport that was simulated using
computer graphics the seattle-tacoma
Airport in the United States
and there was also Bell Labs in New
Jersey also in the US and they meet one
of the first ever computer-generated
films and I just want you to picture
like what that might look like okay and
then I'm gonna show it to you so here it
is it is a simulation of a two gyro
gravity gradient attitude control system
by Iggy's a jack from 1963 and it's
super cute it's a satellite revolving
around a planet so as you can see a lot
of the early graphics they were mostly
designed to model or to maybe just you
know demonstrate some diagrams and so
like this really simple graphics of
straight lines geometric shades black
and white that was sufficient for their
purposes and so this was like okay this
is wonderful so you don't get things
like you know fancy colors or gradients
or anything like that
and yet you know art happen anyway
people took the limits of technology
they had and did something really
wonderful of it so I'm not I'm gonna
talk about three different types of art
I just chose examples from each category
that's more and I'll show you some
oscilloscope art some vector graphics
and some text based art and my attempts
at recreating them so let's start with
oscilloscope all right so cathode ray
oscilloscope
if you've ever been in a lab maybe in
the school your plate is one and this is
what a slow scope is all this is what it
looked like in the 1950s it is a device
that takes electrical signals and
converts them into a visual over here so
here we have a example of a sine wave on
Ellis telescope so this is like a little
bit before you know the IBM 7090
and here on the left is a picture of Ben
Lepofsky he is credited to be one of the
first few people who created electronic
graphics so what I mean by that is that
he will plot interesting patterns onto
the oscilloscope and he would then
photograph them and hear us here is some
of his works and what's really
interesting about them is that you know
they look really cool eerily kind of
organic in a way but I can still tell
they had this in a mathematical quality
to it a few more and around the same
time actually in Europe also that were
there was a movement getting started in
computer art herbert w from he also
created his own electronic network using
oscilloscopes here's some of his work so
the interesting thing to know about this
is that oscilloscopes don't have like a
screenshot button right let us know that
you but then you first screenshot okay
this is going to come out so in order to
capture images what they would do is
that they will set a camera in front of
the screen and leaving it on a long
exposure and captures it captures the
movement of the lines or graphics on the
screen and so what you're seeing here is
not just a single snapshot it is a
combination of events on a screen over
time and so here actually example of the
same like events but two different
phases of it and I think it looks really
beautiful like a ghostly jellyfish haha
and here more works by Lepofsky and so I
was kind of interesting to figure out
like you know how were these meet like I
can you know draw a sideways on a
oscilloscope but how do you get from
that to to that and so there was a
little bit of explanation in a magazine
the featured Laplace sea squirt called
recreational mathematics and in it he
explained that he used things like a
sine wave sort of wave square wave and
Lisa do figures which I'll talk a little
bit about in combination so applying
operations on them to create composite
waves that had really interesting
patterns here's an example of firms work
that it makes it really obvious that
there is a bit of a sine wave thing
going on over there
and I was like house okay I get it but
how how well how it is really mean and
so I attempted to recreate it so I'm
gonna show you a little demo here of
creation of the plus key saw salons
that's what he would call its work I'm
gonna use something called p5.js
which is a graphics drawing library
based on processing the processing
language was designed to make drawing
with code accessible for non-programmers
it's super great if you're interested in
like trying out graphical things I
highly recommend checking it out it's
got really great reference really great
documentation and it has an online
editor which is really easy to use so
good place to start so let's jump to
demo alright so in p5 you will usually
have a global draw function that will
get called to draw a frame of your
animation or visual and so in this I'm
just doing something really simple just
setting the center of the canvas as 0 0
and drawing a tiny little circle here at
0 0 with the width and height of 10
pixels and that's not super interesting
what's more interesting is that you can
animate things so here I'm adding a
little counter and incrementing it
incrementing it at every every frame
that's being drawn and using that value
to position the x-coordinate of the
little circle alright I could draw a
line so x increases you keep on trying
to the right but what's more interesting
is that I can also draw you know a
circle and the formula for a circle is
our sine theta what x equals to R sine
theta and y equals to R cos theta where
R is the radius of your circle
so great now drawing a circle circles
circles are cool but not super
interesting what's more interesting is
that you can mess around if theta and
can multiply it by two different
fragments and you get a pretzel so this
is an example of a Lisa do figure it's a
it's when your sine and cos functions at
different phases and so the creates
really interesting loopy effects all
right so
what I can do now is that I can have the
pretzel and then like a little and draw
an additional point because the pencil
is just one point draw another
additional point that is the ellipse
over here
and I can draw a line between those two
points and you get you know kind of that
but not quite still because this
overlaps and keeps on getting brighter
and brighter so what you can do is that
you could fade out the lines as they're
being drawn and this I imagine would be
what that might sort of look like on the
oscilloscope screen a close
approximation of it so I have actually
the code here in p5 demo I will send out
a link to the slides on my Twitter after
this so you can play of it and you can
saw a mess around with you know some of
the values and run in and see how that
that changes the movements or the
effects it's kind of interesting because
you never know what you gonna get you
just like punching stuff and it's like
oh that looks good or not and then you
just had to figure out like what you're
looking for you can also add color here
I see our drawing straight lines I draw
a drew Bezier curves with a similar idea
and yeah so that's uh that's it for us
let's go Bart next vector graphics so
vector graphics is a really special
place in my heart I really enjoy working
of it to understand why vector graphics
are really important and why I like a
lot of those site pieces were like
mostly lies intermec shapes we need to
understand why what output devices were
available at a time for people who work
to computers so this was before laser
printers you can't really know print a
high definition image really easily like
we do now in order to create really
detailed images people would use the
mechanical plotters you can think of a
plotter as a drawing robot it has a pen
and it can move on the Y or x axis and
across the surface or people and draw on
it so this is a drum printer printer so
it moves the wide based on a which is
paper and an X which is the pen and so
the thing the limitation with fatherís
is that all you have is nearly a robot
arm that draws lines and so you had to
describe your graphics in terms of
vectors so you had a provided
coordinates in which
move around condo colors can do
gradients can be like fancy things and
so a lot of the aesthetic back then had
a lot of like lives especially cosy
lives packed together to create certain
interesting effects and here's one that
I saw a lot off it was everywhere
and the bracele idea is that you take a
geometric shape and then you nest it and
rotate it a little bit and you get this
really cool swirly effect and I was okay
you know interesting like it's just
nested squares whatever and in fact it
was so popular that it was the aesthetic
for cybernetics trendy PT which is the
first ever computer exhibition that
focus on computer art and it was held in
the Institute of Contemporary Arts in
London so it was really big deal at a
time and so the fact that they chose
this for the graphics was like okay I
guess that's really popular all right
you know inspire some imagination so a
little side note about cybernetics
serendipity it was curated by a British
Polish woman Jesse erect heart she's
super amazing because she was one of the
first few people who saw the value in
this work and brought together all this
artists and showcase them and the name
is a reference to the happy chance
discoveries that you make with the
computer because like sometimes you work
of randomness and you don't really know
what's gonna come out and sometimes it's
something really beautiful I saw this
motif being used over and over again in
really interesting ways but I later I
was like okay whatever you know milena I
found out this is actually a
visualization to a calculus problem and
that kind of makes sense because a lot
of early computer artists with people
access the computers so scientist and
mathematicians and so the problem goes
like this
imagine for flies that sit in the
corners of a car table which is square
facing inward they all simultaneously
start walking at the same rate each
directing its motion steadily to its to
fly on its right and the toss in
calculus is to find a path of each and I
look at this now and like you know if
I'm just like trying to solve it on its
own okay cool whatever
I don't really think much about it this
sounds super interesting but if you
visualize it over here if each color
representing the path of a sudden fly
actually looks you get that Sorley
effect
it's really pretty when you draw lines
between each of the different flies here
and I also add a pretty gradient here
are some videos just in case the demo
didn't work you know God have you
prepared and I found out that you can do
this not just before but I could do this
three flies or five or six and because I
have a computer that runs really fast
and I don't have to queue up for it you
know I can run as many times as I want
and what I really like to do with this
shape is to tal it so if you put them
all together these are triangles and
what's really fun to see is that when
you look at this the first Shiva you see
it's not a triangle it's actually this
like Spade like shape and you don't
expect that to come out of this so kind
of like that emergent property here's my
way of squares and it's like a little
mushroom mean like Ram hit shape and its
really really hypnotizing so all right
and now I'm gonna tell you about
text-based art I know some what you are
thinking s key right but not really I'll
get into that so to talk about tech
space art it first me to talk about what
was it like outputting text so there
were CRT monitors but most of the time
when people wanted output they were
printed so here is the line printer from
the 60s I believe and it's called line
printer because it prints by lines and
it does that really fast because it has
a fixed character set you can leap
princes and characters and it's like you
know just goes line by line super great
for printing out texts right and so
people figured out ways to make creative
work to this for example here we have a
couple of pieces of work by Frederick
Hamersley for 1969 and you can tell that
they were printed because of the
perforated edges over here I really like
these too and the interesting thing
about these is that this was actually
create that with something called the
art one programming language and it was
created by Catherine Nash
and Richard it's really almost at a
University of New Mexico
nasha was from the art department and
within switched from the engineering
department and they collaborated to make
this language with the intention to
teach students to make simple computer
graphics and it was notable for its
simplicity and intended primarily as an
introduction to the use of computers for
those without any technological
background and I was like that sounds
familiar
that sounds like tt5 and processing
that's really cool so like art one was
the original processing or p5 this is
from the 60s and if you look at the
documentation it's like well you know it
may look more complicated for art one
but really it's the your API it's kind
of the same thing you pass in this the
center of the lips and then it passing
the size of it and it's like same thing
blowing difference is that I want to get
a punch it on the card and then like you
know do all that but the p5 is just like
type it in it happens magic and another
interesting thing that I noticed was
that even look at a detail of somebody's
pieces you notice that the way that it
creates its depth of texture is by
overlapping characters so remember how
line printers have a fixed set of
characters so in order to get creative
with like more textures and more effects
they would overlap two different
characters together so this piece is
made up entirely of zeros dots dashes
and apostrophes and I thought that was
brilliant because you know you have a
printer you can print like over things
let's do it and I was really inspired by
the fact that this was really art
created by making the most out of the
available technology but then being
really creative like you know what they
had instead of like you know creating in
spite of it so as ASCII art I guess you
know this we still have this today kind
of only difference is that it's not
really as yet it's a Humala ebcdic art
stands for extended binary coded decimal
interchange code which was a character
set supported by diem at a time and it
was even more limited than ASCII and so
I was you can see here at the top of the
card and a character says know how to
see but it's not a lot of characters so
it's kind of curious about like what was
it like working this language you know
this is
cool like original you know I won what
with some things that what features they
have what they choose to include so I
did a little research and it's
surprisingly hard to find things written
about art one the only place where I
found anything significant was in Jesse
I write hats book and in it there was a
little flow chat that described the
workings of the language and it had
literally seven drawing subroutines you
can't draw a line so you can draw solid
rectangles you can draw open rectangles
triangles ellipses quadrants and
exponential curves and that was it I
don't know why it had like solid and
open rectangles but like not saw that
open ellipse I'm not sure but I was like
oh cool like this is really simple or
really straightforward and yet people
can create interesting things out of it
I saw I was inspired to recreate this
using javascript so I have here two
coats on github you can look at it I
still work in progress so please don't
judge uh-huh and and so I was like well
here's the thing I don't have a printer
right I'm not gonna go out and buy a
printer so what's the closest thing that
we have to a printer that's easily
accessible and I settled on the terminal
because bouff output tax limit the
character set wonderful easy to use and
here's an example of a piece of work
that I created using the same rules that
were available in art 1 and here these
are all just meat with triangles but it
has like really interesting a little
like 3d effect you can do colors through
terminals here's one that's actually
inspired by the skirt that I'm wearing
right now so and so you remember how I
talked about how created they got was
that overlapping characters so here's
the thing turns out in a terminal it's
really hot to overlap characters if
you're not using my any external library
you like and curses so I was like okay
what's the best next the next best thing
I got which is accents or diacritical
marks so if you see here for the SS
that's like actually accent at the top
and accent at the bottom
same here this is Asturias and then the
accent with the box around it and I love
my really interesting happy accidents
like the way that you color the
background of the characters
like you know those little bit auto-sync
I kind of like that effect so yeah use
what you have
I use the Unicode that critical marks so
not quite se s key art but Unicode art
and that was really fun to play with and
this really just skims the surface
there's way we waste so much more
history in computer graphics and
computer art in Europe alone and I
actually kill at this top for Europe
because a lot of history came out in
there Germany gave us freedom ocula and
George Neace really prolific computer
artists back in the 70s and Hungary give
us Ramona who was making computer
drawings before computers were thing and
also when computers were thing and not
to forget the entire new tendencies new
tendencies movement in Zagreb in what
was once Yugoslavia but today Croatia
and there's eight hundred page book
written on this so if you want to look
at the titles over here this is an
interesting movement because they
celebrate that like modular procedural
art even before computers were used for
it and as computer became more and more
knowing they also became a part of this
movement
so yeah before and I just want to talk a
little bit about why why go true I
always research like looking at things
from sixty years ago so I think that I
notice especially in the web world is
that we are always looking at you know
what's new what's shiny what can I do
next and we don't take a lot of time to
step back and to look at what has
already been done but it's important to
understand that we didn't all get here
just on our own we really you know were
built on the we really stand on the
shoulders of giants it's really
important to know where you came from
because if you don't know what has
already been done you don't know you
know how to make something new so yeah
this is giving me a lot of pre she asian
for the technology we have today and of
course there is no shame in finding
inspiration from the past you can take
what has really been done and make it
riffin it learned from all these people
who have put in all the work and
creativity to get us where we are here
today and that's all I have for you I
have a blog I write about the stuff if
you're interested but yeah it was such a
pleasure
[Applause]
[Music]